gbagbo est obligé de mentir vous savez
qu'on ne bouge pas pendant le jingle
vous avez cligner de l'oeil à siliana
c'est possible simplement je vous le
dire oui il est officiellement de
boycotter ce cérémonial stupide et
injustifiée voilà c'est ma position et
je viendrai droit bien alors
politiquement quel que soit votre
fidélité à vos engagements de jeunesse
on vous a beaucoup vu ces derniers temps
en compagnie d'alain madelin et vous
avez déclaré d'ailleurs moi un type dans
le programme politique et d'enlever sa
cravate
ça me va vous y trouvez quoi madelin ben
may de là je trouve qu'il a il a un
discours qui est particulièrement
adaptée à l'époque dans laquelle nous
vivons et je trouve qu'il ya une
modernité est une espèce de fraternité
qui émane de ce discours qui à mon sens
devrait rassembler pratiquement toutes
les couches sociales de la nation c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs que je vous le voyez
plus honnêtement je le vois à juste
titre d'ailleurs candidat à la
présidence de la république et j'ai la
ferme intention
et c'est parce que le magnat enlever sa
cravate que vous ne portez plus de
cravate c'est une sorte de mamie c'est
là une sorte de mimétisme que les
méchants troisième millénaire qu'on
admirait canton estime quelqu'un dont on
a envie de lui ressembler c'est un peu
comme pour vous tirez vous aimez vous
êtes mis au sport fait du vélo avec
drucker
tous les dimanches matins avec michel
drucker s'espacent commencé sans ça ça
se passe pas bien pour lui parce qu'il a
un mal de chien me suis pas entraînée ça
fait des années et des années que je
[ __ ] mais sens du terme d'ailleurs et
lui pour le moment ils pédalent plutôt
dans la choucroute c'est à dire que il
nous est arrivé d'ailleurs il n'ya pas
très longtemps d'être filmé par ses
petits copains de la 2 et c'était très
emmerdant mais si j'étais obligé de
j'étais obligé de pédaler dans le vide
pour qu'il puisse le rattraper
j'en passe il dort beaucoup il dort
énormément il économise énormément
je ne sais pas il ya quelques jours et
quelques jurons mais peut-être que
finalement là alors il est beaucoup plus
âgées que moi à drucker donc c'est là où
c'est là la différence pour le téléthon
avait fait 5 fois le tour du
périphérique en vélo 8 est admirable x 8
x 8 x 10 7 minutes 46 secondes quatre
dixièmes alors l'une des raisons de
notre forme aussi pierre aboutissent et
que vous avez vous allez laisser tomber
la drogue d'une façon à peu près
complète sauf les pétards m'enfin bon
ouais une dizaine de pétards par jour
parce que ça remplace cigarettes en face
à arrêter des cigarettes donc vous êtes
obligé de fumer des pétards à la glace
pas de panique tout de même pas dire à
mon avis ce qui est déjà bien
un parseur du périphérique voilà et vous
avez retrouvé votre légendaire énergie
sexuelle qui a fait votre succès faut
bien le dire bien brutale en pierre mais
ya pas que ça donc c'est d'ailleurs
grâce à dieu il y avait cette énergie
sexuelle sinon je serais absolument pas
là où je suis aujourd'hui voilà que
pierre a retrouvé en arrêtant la drogue
son énergie sexuelle on vous a beaucoup
vu cet été avec linda hardy à saint
tropez
oui et meir et du clubbing des collines
il y avait droit au remords il y avait
nagui avec une blonde décolorée arthur
avec le nom de l'éphémère arditi avec
bolloré bruits qui a démarré en tant
d'amour en maribel donc c'est vraiment
tout à son honneur
il a crevé quelle durée je sais pas ce
qu'il va jouer si vous voulez mary beth
il y tient alors oui marie bell à paris
mark bell
il parcourait la petite fouine est
d'ailleurs allé là l'état mary bale ont
le plaisir
c'est joli gaston il ya un an tandis le
faisant il s'appelle mary bale voilà les
cantons enfant va grandir et qui va te
dis à papa ya pas assez de pub sur le
plateau que tu vas faire quoi
concrètement
je vais faire revenir donc oui retourné
là en ce moment avec joyeuses pâques en
province il paraît que c'est surtout la
tournée des boîtes échangistes
c'est à dire que si vous voulez ça fait
quand même une bonne dizaine d'années
que un peu plus même douzaine d'années
que mr barbier ma vie dit que au fond sa
clientèle son public on ne fabrique
qu'en province
et j'ai suivi ce conseil à la lettre et
c'est d'ailleurs blier lui-même qui
m'avait dit que je pouvais justement
profiter voilà l'avantagé des tournées
c'est sa fille voilà et donc ça fait une
bonne douzaine d'années maintenant que
je fais le plus grand de boîtes
échangistes vous donnerai des adresses
va sera sûrement d'ailleurs je connais
j'ai l'intention d'éviter un guide
gaultmillau il ya le nordiste imiter son
graffiti des boîtes échangistes le
arditi avec un âge heard it is the hard
way vous échauffer beaucoup de monde pas
mal votre mercedes vitres fumées sur la
roue et vous fait allumer des cigarettes
par les assistants trouvez pas que c'est
un peu too much pas douter vous savez
moi je vais vous dire quand on a réussi
après tout c'est ouais hein quand on a
du pognon
quand on a du vent et on sait bien dans
éclaboussé tous les ans qu'à se démerder
pour faire les mêmes choses voilà
on reconnait on reconnaît vraiment le
made by means de choc
le libéral le libéral de choc
alors ben on va terminer avec la
littérature et des lectures publiques
aussi dans les villes où vous allez nous
lisez du renaud camus bullies et du
robert brasillach du nietzsche oui bah
c'est des jeux les jeux les découvert
sur le tard et je dois dire que j'ai eu
tort
ouais c'est un manque de culture ne m'a
pas très bon et celui là encore il ya
une parole importante à proférer
aujourd'hui il ya une pensée que qu'on
ne partage pas suffisamment et en
particulier dans les couches basses de
la société qui vers l'iss pas comme tout
le monde le sait et je voudrais être le
chantre au fond de cette parole
la tendance à atteindre et je ne vois
pas pour mais celle elle voulait de
lecture de brasillach sont remarquables
et voilà et l antisémitisme ça me choque
plus du tout un fût un temps où ça vous
énervez maintenant vous vivez avec bah
qu'est ce que vous voulez non seulement
c'est dans l'air du temps alors après
tout pourquoi pas hein
voilà merci